[Music]
on this saturday night stabbing suspect
charged
after a violent attack on author salman
rushdie this man was able to get on the
stage and reach rushdie with no
interference the lingering questions on
how and why it happened
studying seized secret documents
following the raid of donald trump's
florida estate that's a pretty shocking
thing to see undergirding a search
warrant focused on a former president
united states some of the most striking
finds as federal investigators comb the
contents and french supermarkets
scramble for stock you're only about to
take one mustard per person and there's
just
none why they're relying on canada to
end a nationwide shortage of one of
france's most favorite condiments
[Music]
global national with bara nasser
reporting tonight mithu
good evening and thanks for joining us a
day after author salman rushdie was
brutally attacked on stage in upstate
new york investigators have charged the
suspect with attempted murder for
decades the polarizing figure lived
under assassination threats but tonight
as he remains in hospital in serious
condition police are still searching for
a motive as mike trolley reports in our
top story tonight global reaction to the
shocking attack has been mixed but at
least one canadian politician says this
will only strengthen rushdie's resolve
for close to 20 seconds friday morning
witnesses say author salman rushdie
withstood the violent assault
this man was able to get on the stage
and reach rushdie with no interference
a day later rushdie remains on a
ventilator and his agent says he'll
likely lose an eye police have now
charged his alleged assailant 24 year
old hadi matar with attempted murder to
which he's pled not guilty and while
police are still considering motives
early reports suggest matar was
sympathetic to islamic extremism
iran which called for rushdie's murder
in a fatwa in 1989 has not issued an
official reaction
newspapers in tehran keep praise on
matar
i'm so glad because the fatwa against
him finally worked says his tehran
resident the broader reaction around the
world was a mix of shock and outrage in
1992 former ontario premier bob ray was
the first political leader in the world
to publicly meet with rushdie almost
four years after the author went into
hiding they said well would you be
prepared to meet him i said of course
i'd be honored to meet him they said
well would you meet him in public i said
why wouldn't i meet him in public ray
says the pair bonded over a similar
irreverent sense of humor which led to
the famous photo of rey kissing rushdie
on his temple rey says he still receives
letters and the occasional comments from
people critical of that evening over the
years i've become aware as well of
the extent to which some people
resent it and and disliked it
as
on my part
because they identify uh salman rushdie
with somebody who is they claim um
auntie
islam
that says ray couldn't be further from
the truth rushdie he adds was vocal
about his disdain for oppression and
this attack will only strengthen his
resolve
microlight global news toronto
new revelations tonight about the raid
of former u.s president donald trump's
florida home there are reports a trump
lawyer signed a statement in june saying
all files marked as classified and
stored at mar-a-lago had been returned
to the government but when fbi agents
searched the property on monday they
found more as jennifer johnson explains
that's raising questions about whether
trump or his team was fully forthcoming
with federal investigators
federal investigators are now pouring
over those top secret documents taken
from former president donald trump's
florida estate among the most alarming a
collection labeled top-secret sensitive
compartmented information
that's material that can only be viewed
in a secure facility that blocks foreign
eavesdropping and where no cell phones
are allowed why trump took those
documents is still unknown donald trump
is a one-man crime wave the search
warrant also said fbi agents were
pursuing national defense information
that reportedly included classified
documents about nuclear weapons experts
say trump could face criminal charges
including violations of the u.s
espionage act it's a statute that has
been used
in prior criminal prosecutions of
individuals who are in unlawful
possession
of classified information
and that's a pretty shocking thing to
see the former president is reportedly
worried someone in his inner circle
betrayed him and informed the fbi in
social media posts trump called reports
of nuclear weapons documents being
seized a hoax and claimed all the
documents had been declassified which is
untrue but many republicans are still
rallying around the former president we
cannot tolerate this
in america where our great institutions
are welded and abused
in such a way to defeat people's
political enemies as some lawmakers
publicly criticized the fbi for
conducting the raid the bureau is taking
steps to fortify its washington
headquarters putting additional fencing
and razor wire to protect its agents
that comes after a man opened fire on
the fbi office in cincinnati ohio and
was later shot and killed by law
enforcement at least one republican is
denouncing the violence
i'm disgusted by the attacks on fbi
agents both the fbi and the department
of justice are under intense scrutiny as
some republicans try to politicize the
raid the current fbi director
christopher wray was actually appointed
by trump in 2017 and the attorney
general who signed off on the warrant is
defending the agents who carried out the
raid as patriotic public servants
jennifer johnson global news washington
next week canada's largest annual fair
will reopen its gates for the first time
in two years after a lengthy pandemic
shutdown the canadian national
exhibition says it's expecting huge
crowds for the two-week event in toronto
but a labor dispute involving ontario
safety inspectors has led to questions
about ride safety at this year's fair
morgan campbell explains
it may be the rides games or even the
food that attracts more than 1.5 million
people to the canadian national
exhibition in toronto each year but
instead of touting all that the event
has to offer elected officials are
defending mounting concerns it will be
safe we will make sure it's safe and
that's our responsibility a labor
dispute between the technical standards
and safety authority known as the tsa in
ontario and its inspectors has led to a
strike after contract talks recently
broke down employees walked off the job
at the end of july
picketing outside of traveling and fixed
amusement parks like canada's wonderland
without them in the oversight there's
definitely a potential for some risk to
the public the safety inspectors do more
than just inspect amusement park rides
they look after elevators ski lifts and
food trucks in addition to fuel burning
equipment gas stations and nuclear power
plants while the 170 workers pick it the
tssa has brought in managers and hired
consultants to assist with inspections
all of those rides will have been had
their tssa inspection by highly
qualified
employees of tssa words echoed by an
expert in engineering and safety of
amusement park rides in an email to
global news professor catherine woodcock
writes that owner operators of rides and
devices are required to carry insurance
and the insurance provider's risk
mitigation expectations are in full
force notwithstanding the strike during
an agricultural fair last weekend in
campbellford a town just northeast of
toronto a ride malfunctioned no one was
seriously injured but the incident
prompted an investigation by the tssa
it found issues with the car leading to
potential legal implications
that kind of thing
you know we should never see that in
ontario everybody is concerned
about the safety of
people in ontario the union maintains it
will continue to pick it until both
sides get back to the bargaining table
morgan campbell global news
a warning that our next story may be
upsetting to some viewers as questions
surround the tragic discovery of human
remains at a low-income apartment
building in vancouver global news has
learned they should have been found
months earlier but members of the
coroner service didn't show up when they
were supposed to as sarah mcdonald
reports it's another example of
investigative oversight regarding the
tragic death of a 13-year-old girl
it's been more than a week since the
grim timeline and the embarrassing
investigative oversight by multiple
agencies in the tragic case of noello
soup were made public and still silence
from virtually every agency that dropped
the ball from the day this 13 year old
vanished from foster care to the
discovery of her decomposed remains
which went overlooked for months inside
a cramped unit in this vancouver housing
complex alongside those of a woman in
her 30's the person who went without a
name for
up until this moment for me who is she
who are her people
why didn't we matter why didn't any of
us matter global news has learned she
that second dead female is closely
related to a serving member of the
vancouver police department which has
repeatedly refused comments on this case
as one of its own officers grieves the
loss of a loved one and another now
faces a neglect of duty probe by the
office of the police complaint
commissioner i'm sure i'm not the only
one who mentioned it smells like death
finn o'reilly is one of multiple
residents of this privately owned single
room occupancy building who raised
repeated concerns of an overwhelming
stench emanating from unit 16 where we
now know the tenant a man in his 40's
had been living alongside those
decomposed remains for weeks if not
months before his own sudden death i
talked to the person who
is supposed to run the place
hey man smells like death in the hallway
smells like death in the hallway you
should
find out like what's the deal with the
trash in there it smells like death in
the hallway and i was just being off the
cuff
smells bad really bad i didn't realize
it was actual death something global
news has learned the bc coroner's
service didn't realize initially either
because according to sources the coroner
did not show up when that tenant died
suddenly in february meaning nobody
conducted a thorough search of the suite
until cleaning crews did
more than two months later only then
finding those other two bodies the
deaths of both females considered
suspicious
one of the things that hopefully
are able to be provided as this case
is examined is that we find out exactly
how it happened what mistakes were made
why things went wrong the coroner won't
comment on this case setting a still
open investigation but when asked if the
service's mandate to attend all sudden
unnatural deaths has changed confirmed
it has not telling global news coroners
are expected to attend the scene of any
reported death that appears to meet the
criteria for investigation there are
rare instances in which we are unable to
physically attend the scene adding
suspected illicit drug toxicity deaths
are handled in the same manner as all
other investigations whenever possible
coroners attend the scenes of death and
direct the postmortem processes that
really ticks me off big for this
neighbor the investigative oversight at
seemingly every turn is infuriating if
this building was in west vancouver they
would have turned that room over within
24 hours
we live here in east vancouver where we
don't matter
they didn't matter but to her
not surprising
sarah mcdonald global news
coming up forced to flee in japan as a
tropical storm releases heavy rain and
winds
plus deadly gang violence turns on
civilians near mexico's border with the
u.s
tropical storm miri has made landfall in
japan the weather system is unleashing
heavy rains and powerful winds more than
72 thousand people have been told to
flee their homes just southwest of tokyo
due to possible mudslides there's also
concern the storm could cause flooding
miri is now moving north toward tokyo
it's expected to head back out to the
pacific ocean tomorrow
one person is dead and about 40 others
are in hospital after a stage collapse
at a music festival in spain
organizers of the medusa festival say
strong winds are to blame they say they
had ordered the concert grounds cleared
when the wind intensified around 4 a.m
the collapse happened shortly after that
the festival has been canceled for the
rest of the weekend with organizers
saying today is a day of mourning nearly
a dozen people are dead after violence
broke out between rival cartels in the
mexican city of ciudad juarez just
across the border from el paso texas the
fighting started inside the state prison
on thursday ending with two inmates dead
and 20 others injured suspected gang
members outside the prison then began
burning businesses and opening fire on
each other at least nine civilians were
killed in the crossfire at least 600
soldiers have been deployed to the city
in hopes of restoring peace
ahead black sea grain shipment success
the hopes for the coming months as more
ships set sail
two more cargo ships left ukraine's
black sea ports today marking a total of
16 ships to have departed from the
region since a u.n broker deal reopened
the crucial trade corridor in july some
450 000 tons of agricultural products
including grain are said to have left
the country since the agreement between
ukraine russia turkey and the u.n last
month ukraine says it hopes to ramp up
exports to more than 3 million tons a
month in the near future after being
stalled for five months due to the war
the fighting within ukraine continued to
intensify today both sides are once
again trading accusations of shelling
around the zaparisia nuclear plant
europe's largest facility of its kind
and fierce fighting was reported in the
south as ukraine wages a
counter-offensive towards the russian
occupied city of hair saun
in some of these key battles civilians
have increasingly become pivotal to
securing victory jeff semple was in kiev
earlier this summer and gathered a
global news exclusive about the civilian
drone pilots helping ukraine's military
near the front line
last summer andre pocarasa saved up
enough money to buy a drone
the 15 year old practiced flying every
day at his home near kiev
i'm afraid of heights but i love flying
he says i like taking pictures from up
high
but in february pocarasa's town suddenly
found itself on russia's warpath russian
tanks were spotted heading their way
ukraine's military didn't know the exact
location so they began looking for a
drone pilot drones have been a tool of
war for years but ukraine has witnessed
a proliferation of these consumer level
drones which can be owned and operated
by almost anyone from almost anywhere
giving the ukrainian military
potentially thousands of eyes in the
skies it's like game changer for for the
world this drone shop owner says when
russia invaded ukraine's military didn't
have any short-range drones so he put
out a call on facebook for civilian
drone owners to help locate russian
forces the response was overwhelming if
we
didn't have such operators and drones
who can help ukrainian army i think
kiu already could be occupied by
russian
forces more than a thousand civilians
answered the call to help including the
youngest volunteer pokharasa
the russians were only a couple of
kilometers away but the military needed
their exact coordinates pogarasa was the
only experienced drone pilot in town
i was very scared but if i didn't help
them the russians could be here in a day
he says the grade 9 student went with
his father to a nearby field and put his
drone up over the highway before long he
spotted an armored column of russian
vehicles his father sent the images and
coordinates to the military and the
russian column was destroyed pokhara's
town was saved is she proud
his mother says it was a sleepless night
yes
i had no way of contacting them i was so
worried she says after that she insisted
they leave to poland with russian forces
now pushed out of this region the family
returned home last week
the military rewarded pocarasa with this
more advanced drone and he says proudly
he's also gained more followers on tick
tock after posting some of his videos
i was so happy that i helped he says but
also there were people in those russian
vehicles they were occupiers but still
people i don't know how to explain how i
feel about it
[Music]
the weight of the experience is a lot to
carry even for the bravest 15 year old
jeff semple global news near key
next how france's mustard shortage was
cultivated in canada and when it could
end
[Applause]
[Music]
the most beloved reptile in nova scotia
is celebrating a major milestone this
weekend gus the gopher tortoise is now
100 years old or close enough to it the
nova scotia museum of natural history
isn't sure exactly when his birthday is
but tortoises usually hatch around this
time of year in the wild gopher
tortoises generally live to be about 60
years old
the world isn't the same place it was
prior to the pandemic resources are
harder to come by for a myriad of
reasons france is going through a
particularly painful shortage and canada
is playing a key role
mike trolley reports
the streets of paris certainly seem calm
but underneath the laissez-faire
exterior a crisis is spreading and it's
unclear just how the french will get
through the great mustard shortage of
2022. mustard shortage is literally real
you're only about to take one mustard
per person and there's just
none
for centuries french cuisine has used
mustard in virtually everything today
the french consume on average a kilo of
the stuff per person per year so you can
imagine the reaction when grocery store
shelves began to look like this
it wasn't long before desperation led to
hoarding so they've been rationing
essentially they've been trying to
limit the number of bottles people can
buy per visit
they've been very careful because they
know that things are tight
call it a french tragedy albeit with
canadian roots let me explain you see
while it's widely known that canada is
the top exporter of maple syrup in the
world we're also number one in potash
flax lentils blueberries
and yes mustard you could say nobody
cuts the mustard without canada there's
no cartel and mustard like there's a
cartel in maple syrup but not in mustard
even if there was there's nothing a
mustard cartel could have done about the
droughts that led to a 50 drop in
mustard seed production last year
french importers didn't panic because
they knew they could make up the
shortfall with seeds grown in russia and
ukraine
or so they thought
the good news is that canada's 2022
crops look promising so the shortage
should end in 2023
until then the french will have to
endure some online needling
i wonder how they'll take it oh wait i
know
hold the mustard
mike drollate global news toronto
and that is global national for this
saturday night i'm nithu garcia
tonight's year canada is french creek
harbor in parksville bc we love seeing
your canada please keep sending your
photos to viewers at globalnational.com
thanks for watching hope you'll join us
again tomorrow have a great night
[Music]